[Musique]
e
paulus et le secret du château de la
mort lente
[Musique]
e
oh
paulus le dernier fils du sabotier
laisse à tomber ça bouge et s'écria
voilà la 301e père de sabo que je fais
et ce sera la dernière
quand j'en aurais fait encore trois fois
autant j'en serai seulement - je n'ai
plus fatigués mais sûrement pas plus
riche ce soir même je vais chercher
fortune ailleurs la mairie beau pleurer
et supplier et répété que celle-ci fils
l'avait quittée ainsi sans jamais
rapporté la fortune rien n'y fit le père
en tradant une furieuse scolaire et
hurle à vatan au diable mon fils pour
lui ce battant au diable et que je ne te
revois pas ni le chagrin de sa mère ni
la colère de son père ne pouvait faire
revenir pour lui sur sa décision
ils se sentaient forts comme un homme
est capable de tout affronter pour lui
c'est est grand pour ses saisons à force
de couper les arbres de charrier le bois
et de le creuser il s'est amusé les bras
et jambes
ses parents avaient cru pendant
longtemps que les cheveux couleur feu de
leur dernier fils ses yeux vérité selon
lui porterait bonheur dans la vie il lui
avait même fait apprendre à lire
lorsque paul hus pas ça le seuil de la
pauvreté zon son maigre baluchon au bout
d'un bateau le père lui cria pour la
troisième fois
va-t'en au diable paulus ne se retourne
à pas mais pour chasser le mauvais sort
que son père appelait sur lui il murmura
que le diable ne vous entendent pas et
reste dans son enfer on lui ce n'avait
qu'une idée en tête aller en ville
chercher du travail
mais la ville était à plus d'une journée
de marche et pour s'y rendre
paulus devait traverser tout l'immense
forêt de la mort lente que l'on disait
en t il pénétra sans hésiter dans le
sous bois le sentier qu'il suivait passé
entre d'immenses trous noirs dont les
pêches feuillage les c'est à peine
passer la lumière du jour
le grand silence qui habitaient ces
lieux ne donnait pas envie de traîner ni
de s'arrêter le garçon marche à des
heures sans en prendre un chant d'oiseau
sans croiser le moindre gibier et la
nuit approchait
tout à coup dans la demi-heure de
sécurité un léger craquement le fit
sursauter
pour l'uss s'arrêta le coeur battant à
toi pas devant lui
au détour du sentier un petit homme
habillé tout en noir apparu soudain il
approchait étonné de cette rencontre
pour lui ça lui à l'inconnu et voulu
s'écarter pour le laisser passer
l'homme s'arrêta et le dévisage a pour
lui son fit autant le visage anguleux au
nez crochu et au talent évident du petit
homme n'avait rien d'engageant porte est
un curieux chapeau noir qui lui cachait
le front et le haut du crâne sous ses
épais sourcils ses yeux brillaient comme
des braises et la bouche ne souriez pas
l'homme tout habillés de noir par là le
premier n'a pas encore parcouru la
moitié de la forêt dit-il d'une voix
sèche et rauque
pourquoi dont 28 en ville pour trouver
du travail qui polluent s'étonner que
l'inconnu et deviner ses intentions et
pourquoi les 6 - alors que je peux t'en
procurez vous auriez dû travail pour moi
s'exclame à paul hus voulant croire à sa
chance malgré l'air sinistre du
personnage comme il voudrait tout gagné
repris la voie sèche 50 et q10 paulus
qui n'en avait jamais vu tant je t'en
donnerai le triple si tu veux venir chez
moi comme domestiques premier l'homme
noir mais tout à coup il sembla se
raviser tu ne sais pas lire au moins
paulus qui était pourtant fière de son
savoir senti qu'il devait mentir s'il
voulait obtenir ce travail il répondit
les renier
pour sûr que non monsieur j'ai bien été
à l'école quelquefois mais il n'y a pas
une lettre pas un chiffre qui me soient
entrés dans la cervelle suis moi dit
seulement l'homme noir dont le visage ne
laissait rien paraître
sans explication l'homme pris le premier
sentier sur la droite
paulus marche a derrière lui le garçon
aurait bien voulu poser quelques
questions à l'inconnu qui venait ainsi
de l'engager mais il ne dit mot se
contentant de suivre le mystérieux
personnage houle en méthyl avec il bien
fait de lui mentir
paulus inquiet s'interrogeait la nuit
était tout à fait tomber quand il se
tourne vers soudain devant canon d'une
hauteur fantastique
à ce moment le vent dû souffler car les
arbres ce mirage et moore un oiseau de
nuit lança un hululement sinistre auquel
l'écho répondit dans le moteur pour les
supprimant très froid un bruit de claix
fit sursauter le garçon c'était dans la
lah connu allait le faire entrer dans sa
demeure
à part te sont les minuscules au bas de
la muraille l'homme overy 3 sony de
verrous et la pousse à
[Musique]
dans le silence paulus frissonna au
grincement lugubre dgo lundi le garçon
pensa à la porte d'une prison de l'autre
côté du mur il n'y avait aucun arbre un
énorme shadow dressé sur un piton
rocheux aucune lumière aux rares
fenêtres
la fantastique silhouette éclairé par
les reflets changeants de la lune
ben là ça le malheureux pour lui ce
qu'ils pensent a aussitôt que son
mensonge lui porter malheur comme la
boutique du sabotier lui paraissait
lointaine voici ma demeure
10 seulement le petit homme noir pour
lui ce fut incapable de répondre
je pensais que c'était le château de la
mort lente comme la forêt qui l'entouré
il montait en silence jusqu'à la porte
d'entrée est l'énorme oiseau de nuit
dérangé par leur présence frôla la tête
de paul hus cuts sur sont de nouveau le
petit hameau vrie trois verrous et la
porte du château grâce à la salle était
immense et glacé
par qui la table avait elle été préparée
les torches allumées paulus ne s'en
inquiète pas il devra la soupe et le
fromage tandis que les pas saccadés de
son étrange m résonnaient dans la pièce
voisine l'estomac bien plein tombant de
fatigue et de sommeil pour lui ça brille
enfin en quoi consisterait son service
qui devra d'abord veiller à ce que nul
être humain ne pénètre mon château
pendant les longues absences l'unisson
mètres d'une voie de la sial dont le
travail consistera à ranger a gardé les
3333 livre de ma bibliothèque qui sera
aussi ta chambre
souviens-toi qu'aucun oeil humain n'a le
droit de les lire rappelle toi que tu ne
devra jamais te préoccuper de ce que je
fais il te demander où je vais si mes
habitudes de semble étrange c'est que tu
ne peux pas les comprendre tout ce qui
est bizarre étrange mystérieux dans mon
château de la mort lente ne te concerne
pas eh bien vous être finie partir pour
l'us abasourdi par ce long discours est
fort étonné de ses fonctions et tu ne
pourra sortir qu'une fois l'an ajouta le
maître l'air méchant suis moi maintenant
paulus se lever péniblement les marches
a de nouveau derrière son maître qui
avait pris l'une des tanches
ils traversèrent toute la salle gravir
un escalier qui parut énorme office du
sabotier il lui sembla monter une
cinquantaine de marche
le bruit de leurs pas et est
impressionnant dans le silence et
plusieurs fois pour lui ce cru voir des
êtres mystérieux semblable à des démos
se profiler contre les murs il celui ci
est ensuite dans un long couloir sur
lequel donnait de nombreuses portes tout
fermer le mettre ton à plusieurs fois
descendirent monta encore démarche tout
à coup pour lui se retourna sentons une
présence dans son dos
[Musique]
mais derrière lui tout était vide et
parfaitement voir enfin arriver à la
bibliothèque pour lui suite à la lumière
de la torche que la pièce était petit
ces quatre murs étaient couverts de
livres du sol au plafond par une fenêtre
aux places est grillagé très étroite
la lumière froide de la lune pénétrait
dans un coin un matelas lui étaient
destinées voici les clefs de la
bibliothèque l'unisson m d'une voiture
il devra toujours fermé la porte à
double tour
puis le maître sortie en portant la
tanche police n'avait plus que la
lumière bleuâtre de la lune pour
éclairer la mystérieuse bibliothèque
dont il avait la garde sans s'émouvoir
des reflets qui passait sur les murs ni
de l'étrangeté de son nouveau destin il
s'endormit d'un sommeil de plomb lorsque
le garçon s'éveilla il faisait grand
jour pour lui ce jeu tu as un coup
d'oeil aux livres il était si vieux
qu'il semblait avoir été là de toute
éternité
le garçon se promet bien d'en lire
autant qu'il voudrait malgré la défense
express du maître des lieux pour lui
sorti de la bibliothèque qui sont
pressés d'aller prendre les ordres de
son nouveau maître
après avoir erré un bon moment dans des
lieux dont qu'il n'avait aucun souvenir
il retrouve à l'immense couloirs aux
portes fermées entrevue à la lumière de
la torche
il y faisait sombre même en plein jour
et un tremblement bizarre agité toutes
les portes
paulus préféré ne pas s'y attarder
mais il lui fallut un long moment le
temps d'essayer plus de 20 portes avant
de trouver celle qui conduisait tocantes
escaliers il descendit et ne trouva
personne ni dans la grande salle où ils
avaient dîné dans les pièces voisines
complètement noir lorsqu'il clia mon
maître savoir en flat enfla se répercuta
sur les murs vides sans réponse
paulus était bien seul dans le château
de la mort lente
l'escale se rétrécissait et descendez
plus bas vers les sous sols sans doute
pour lui ce sans penser à prendre une
tanche s'y aventurent à le premier
corridor qu'il emprunta étaient étroits
et noir il attira pourtant pour lui ce
qui avançait en tâtant les murs quand il
se retourne à la lumière qui venait de
l'escalier et aurait pu le guider pour
remonter avait disparu pour lui ce ne va
pas crier une seconde fois il erra
longtemps dans ce labyrinthe et tout à
coup il lui semble entendre le tip tap
d'une pendule qui me battait comme un
coeur c'était presque une présence
il essayait de s'en approcher
mais en vain
la distance semblait toujours la même
depuis longtemps pour lui ce ne savait
plus où il en était et il semblait que
l'air lui manque c'est alors que la
clarté de l'escalier lui apparu quand il
arriva à la cuisine il trouva du pain du
fromage et de la soupe et mangea à sa
fin un nouveau tour dans le château lui
confirma qu'il n'y avait à mme qui
vivent en dehors de la sienne dans le
château de la mort lente et quand paul
hus sortie pour revoir la ferai les
remparts étaient si haut qu'il n'a perçu
même pas la cime des arbres
la petite porte au bas de la muraille et
est bardée de trois serrures
le malheureux garçon remonte à
tristement dans la bibliothèque est
voulue parcourir les livres dont il
avait la charge
hélas quelle déception
il était rempli de caractère au qui ne
comprenaient rien absolument rien malgré
sa curiosité son application
le soir tombé
paulus pensait avoir essayé de lire plus
de 100 volume quand il tombe par hasard
sur un petit livre qui pouvaient
déchiffrer et quelle surprise en tête du
premier chapitre i put lire formule
diabolique pour découvrir ce qui vous
est caché et puis formule diabolique
pour vous transporter d'un endroit à
l'autre et encore formule pour ouvrir
tout ce qui est fermé et comment le
diable peut vous changer en ce que vous
voulez pour l'us poussaient des cris de
joie à chaque découverte sans
s'inquiéter de leur écot à travers le
château comme il avait bien fait
d'apprendre à lire et de cacher son
savoir à son maître avec ses formules
magiques il pouvait s'enfuir de sa
prison sinistre gagner de l'argent
retrouvé ses parents mais d'abord et
avant tout paulus où les savoirs qui
était son maître et où ils étaient ils
regardent à la formule diabolique pour
découvrir ce qui vous est caché il
prononça trois fois comme nos crs à
perevi d'airé en pensant très fort à son
maître
alors en voyant ce qu'il voulait voir
paulus poussins écrit dépôt-vente le
diable le diable est mon maître j'habite
chez le diable le veux de mon père a été
exaucé pour l'uss venait de voir un
instant l'enfer il avait reconnu son
maître dans son habit noir essayant de
faire basculer dans les flammes
les malheureux homme qui l'avait fait
damner pour lui se pouvait partir quand
ils voudraient de ce château grâce aux
formules magiques qu'il venait de
découvrir mais il en savait trop pour
s'enfuir sans se venger du démon il
allait attendre de pied ferme le retour
de son maître
d'abord à la bibliothèque en apprenant
par coeur toutes les formules puis dans
la vaste cuisine où il ferait chauffé au
rouge les normes four à pain pour luce
avait son idée
trois nuits plus tard la porte des
remparts grèce pour lui c'est est prêt
le four était aussi ce ne pouvait être
que son maître le diable paulus a tant
dit écoute 1
la porte du château grâce à ce tour pour
lui ce ne tremblait pas alors la porte
de la cuisine s'ouvrit enfin paulus le
grand garçon aux cheveux roux comme le
feu se jeta sur une petite somme toute
habillée de noir au teint livide au nez
crochu à la bouche mauvaise lorsque dans
le combat le chapeau noir du petit homme
roula sur le sol
pour l'uss vie ses deux cornes dans sa
fureur d'avoir été trompé par le diable
il empoigna par les deux épaules élan
fournas dans le four à pain dont il
referma la porte pour lui se murmure a
immédiatement trois fois portu rue
sportura ouvre atom et toutes les portes
du château s'ouvrir
sauf celle du four à pain une fois
arrivé dans la forêt de la mort lente
paulus reprises sa respiration et répète
à trois fois vol virus à l'us transporta
tous c'était la formule diabolique qui
devait le ramener chez ses bas hélas
pour lui ce que nous appelle la maison
du sabotier
et fleurs qui l'entouraient avaient
perdu leur couleur l'herbe lui
paraissait grise plus s'approcher d'une
fenêtre et ce qu'il vit l'épouvantail
deux yeux de braise l'observer et ce
visage au nez crochu à la bouche
méchante qui se reflétait dans la vitre
noir c'était son image en volant les
secrets du diable il était devenu diable
lui même
[Musique]